foreign
Nashville hi Ashley how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um so I just wanted to get your own
opinion
and I have a friend that does your house
program as well as I've been doing it
since 2020 I'm still in babysit too and
we discussed it a few times but I'm just
not sure of my decision so in 2019 we
adopted our son
and then a year later our marriage fell
apart and we split up so fast forward to
now
um well we've been to court two times
over custody issues
a lot of nonsense really his dad's just
really hard to get along with
um so but in those two times it's cost
me around 20 to 25 000 in court
returning fees and everything else so um
I'm trying to
just gain some traction on
maybe preparing for that in the future
because I feel like it's not going away
and still being able to pay off my bed I
really just don't know what to do
hmm I'm sorry Ashley
that's really yeah that's a that's a
really hard situation
um
how much how much money do you make a
year
um so I work as much overtime as I can
um I tried last year I made around 100 a
hundred thousand and then um this year
it's probably going to be between 80 and
90. okay what do you do
I'm a nurse yeah good for you
thank you uh how much how much debt in
general do you have
um all together is probably around
ninety thousand and it's a mixture of
vehicles uh to well my vehicle alone and
then
um I have
some credit cards in a line of credit at
the bank
audio in your car
uh 25. okay so you have 90 000 in debt
and 25 of its car and then how much of
its credit cards
um around nine thousand
okay so the rest of it is what
um
credit
and
I'm not sure I can't think of anything
else so I might be wrong that's only 45
that's only 54 000.
so I have another vehicle my name but I
don't taste work so that's another 48
000 but that's not mine what in the
world who what is that
it's his truck but he makes all the
payments on that it doesn't cost me
anything but we went in together to get
it so
so your name is on the is it on the deed
on the on the loan on the title of the
truck
yeah yeah
but the divorce decree gave him the
truck and you're supposed to pay it or
he's supposed to pay it
so that's not his no that's like my
fiance that I have now I'm sorry
oh you so you have a so you bought a
truck for your fiance for fifty thousand
dollars
so we went in to get her I didn't
necessarily buy it for him and we it's
something that we just done together
he needed you to co-sign it
no no he I mean he's doing good with his
money you know he no he's not he took
out a 50 000 truck loan with his money
um why are you on the loan
uh because I mean we're we're getting
married and um I just I don't know it
was when are you getting married
uh hopefully within the next year okay
all right in in the whole story that you
told us
that has a lot of uh tragedy and sadness
this thing then jumps up as super stupid
and crazy
right like a fifty thousand dollar truck
while you're fighting and don't have the
money to pay and you have to take out a
line of credit
and and the best idea y'all got to go in
debt for 50 Grand on a truck while
you're trying to keep a dadgum child in
a custody battle on going with a crazy
ex
yeah this crook is crazy
nuts crazy yeah
yeah
so um all right so you're getting
married when did you say
probably within a year okay uh
why are you waiting
um honestly because everything's just
been
just for the past two years
two years and I've dealt with
um anxiety and depression
um my son has a lot of issues he was
born with
and none of that's changing in a year
I'm sorry none of that is changing in a
year
and my main focus being my son right
that's just not been at the top of the
list I guess okay you called and asked
us for help and we love you and we want
you to win and we're sad that you're
having to fight to keep your baby okay
now then I'm going to tell you some hard
stuff are you okay with that
yes okay sell the stupid truck
get married
now
or don't
but don't wait around on some mythical
Island to Come Sailing up some mythical
ship to Come Sailing up to your Island
when everything's going to be right
because the things you've been facing
part of your anxiety and part of the
things you've been facing with mental
health stuff is not just your ex it's
this pile of stuff on you and all of
these un uh
untied knots knots that need to be tied
okay right you don't have closure on
anything all these open-ended things or
there's open ended this open-ended that
open into this there's no closure
anywhere and that creates angst it
creates anxiety so
um yeah you've got to get some some
predictable order not chaos the more
areas of your life you can get non-chaos
in the the faster your anxiety is going
to drop I'm not a mental health
professional Dr John delonius I've just
heard him say that so I said it okay but
that's the truth okay so and these you
know and the debt and the pile of debt
you guys have you have and now you guys
with this fifty thousand dollar truck is
part of where your anxiety is coming
from because you don't you feel trapped
and now you're you're worried about the
next time the crazy ex comes at you how
are we going to cover that meantime I
got a 48 000 truck note
okay and I know he takes care of it
Ashley but the truth is though if he
doesn't it's on you then and so you're
carrying this around your neck you feel
it in your between your shoulder blades
you feel the weight of it and that's
part of the anxiety you can't keep from
doing that by the way it's just how your
body and your mind and your spirit works
so yeah if I if you were my little
sister or my daughter I would tell you
get married
and sell the truck by the weekend
or run this guy off and sell the truck
by the weekend but painter get off the
ladder
right okay that's what I would tell you
to do if I loved you and I do so I want
you to do that okay and then we want you
to uh take this wonderful income you
have and you have a fabulous career
choice because you'll always have a job
and you can always make money when
you're a nurse it's just a great job and
actually I would sell your car honestly
I would get any level of traction for 25
000 I'm like you can get a used ten
thousand dollar whatever it is but just
I would I would get out of that how hard
would you work how crazy would you go to
have twenty thousand dollars in the bank
and no debt so next time crazy X comes
around you can punch him in the nose
with a lawyer
right well that's what I thought I was
doing this last time exactly and now but
you didn't you went over the car lot
with your goober fiance and bought a
truck
right okay so you went the other way so
I want you to sell everything in sight
work like crazy people live on beans and
rice rice and beans get married and
let's get the credit card debt paid off
I mean all of it yeah start getting some
traction with that debt payoff Ashley
and I think you're going to start to
feel more in control because you are
that's why you'll feel that way because
you're going to run the chaos off and
drive order in and and build a build a
build a war chest to go to war